WHATEVER, GIVING PEOPLE LIKE
YOU POWER IS FRIGHTENING.
THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
I'M OUT.
BECAUSE I CAN'T GET A
STRAIGHT ANSWER FROM YOU:
AUTHOR AND COLUMNIST MARK
STEYN JOINS US TONIGHT.
MARK?
>> BY THE WAY WE HAD A GUN
REGISTRY IN CANADA THAT WAS
A COMPLETE FIASCO.
IT TURNED OUT TO BE -- IT
GOT COMPLETELY INFECTED WITH
INACCURATE INFORMATION AND I
THINK THE CANADIAN TAXPAYERS
WOUND UP SPENDING $600 PER
GUN REGISTRATION BECAUSE IT
BECAME JUST ANOTHER
POINTLESS INACCURATE
GOVERNMENT BOONDOGGLE.
>> Tucker: WHY IS IT THAT
THE PEOPLE -- THERE ARE A
LOT OF REASONS THESE THINGS
HAPPEN AND ULTIMATELY THEY
ARE THE FAULT OF THE GUY WHO
DOES IT THE GUY WHO PULLS
THE TRIGGER.
IF GOVERNMENT IS TELLING WE
CAN KEEP YOU SAFE.
YOU HAVE NO RIGHT TO PROTECT
YOURSELF AND WE'LL PROTECT
YOU AND THEN THEY DON'T AND
WON'T ADMIT AND PERSIST IN
TRYING TO PREVENT FROM YOU
PROTECTING YOURSELF.
DOESN'T THAT SUGGEST THAT
MAYBE SOMETHING IS NOT ON
THE LEVEL HERE?
>> YES.
AND I THINK ACTUALLY THIS
GETS TO THE HEART OF IT.
IF YOU WERE TO LOOK AT THIS
SCHOOL COP, SO-CALLED, IF
SCHOOL COP, SO-CALLED, HF
SCHOOL COP, SO-CALLED, HIS
BEHAVIOR IS AS REPORTED GOOD
EXAMPLE OF WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
YOU MASSIVELY EXPAND LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
THE PROPORTION OF BAD
POLICING THE POLICE WHO LET
YOU DOWN WILL INCREASE AND
IT WILL EVENTUALLY BE LIKE
THE TSA WHEN YOU GO TO THE
CONVEYOR BELT AND TAKE YOUR
SHOES OFF AND NINE PEOPLE
STANDING AROUND.
HOW MANY OF THEM WOULD
ACTUALLY RESPOND EFFECTIVELY
IN THE SITUATION.
THAT'S THE FIRST PROBLEM.
THE SECOND PROBLEM SERIOUS
ABOUT GUN CONTROL, YOU WOULD
HAVE TO CHANGE THE MINDS OF
TENS OF MILLIONS OF AMERICAN
LAW ABIDING AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
>> Tucker: EXACTLY.
>> YOU WOULD NOT STAGE THE
SPECTACLE THAT CNN STAGED
LAST NIGHT.
WHICH BROUGHT BACK MEMORIES
TO ME.
15 YEARS AGO.
YOU REMEMBER A SENATOR, HE
DIED IN A PLANE CRASH, VERY
SAD, THEY HELD A FUNERAL AND
TURNED IT INTO AN UGLY
PARTISAN POLITICAL REALITY.
TO SPEAK -- SPEAKING AS A
FOREIGNER, YOU KNOW,
AMERICANS, THE GUN --
PRIVATE GUN OWNERSHIP IS
CENTRAL TO AMERICANS SENSE
OF THEMSELVES IN A WAY THAT
IT IS NOT TO AUSTRALIANS,
FOR EXAMPLE.
AND THAT, TO CHANGE THAT
REQUIRES CALM, THOUGHTFUL,
RATIONALE DEBATE RATHER THAN
EMOTIONAL EXHIBITIONISM OF
THE KIND ON DISPLAY LAST
NIGHT.
>> Tucker: I THINK YOU MADE
THE KEY POINT RIGHT, THERE
WHICH IS YOU NEED TO
CONVINCE PEOPLE.
YOU CAN'T CHANGE HUNDREDS OF
YEARS OF LAW AND CUSTOMS
SIMPLY BY FIAT OR SCREAMING
OR THREATENING PEOPLE IN A
DEMOCRACY YOU HAVE TO BRING
PEOPLE ALONG WITH YOU.
YOU HAVE TO NOT COMPEL THEM
BUT CONVINCE THEM.
AND THE LEFT DOESN'T SEEM
INTERESTED IN THAT AT ALL.
>> NO.
AND I THINK THIS IS ACTUALLY
WHERE IT'S GOING WRONG.
I WOULD SAY, FOR EXAMPLE,
THAT IF YOU LOOK AT GERMANY
AND SCANDINAVIA WHERE POLICE
CHIEFS TELL WOMEN THAT IT'S
NOT SAFE TO GO OUT ALONE AT
NIGHT SINCE THEY LET ALL THE
REFUGEES IN TO THE COUNTRY,
YOU HAVE DECLINING SOCIAL
TRUST WHICH IS LIKELY TO
MOVE EUROPEANS BACK TOWARDS
A SELF-DEFENSE MODEL.
NOW, HAVE YOU DECLINING
SOCIAL TRUST IS ONE OF THE
PHENOMENA OF OUR TIMES HERE
IN AMERICA.
AND WHEN PEOPLE LOOK AT THAT
INCOMPETENT AND WEASELLY
SHERIFF LAST NIGHT BATTERING
DANA LOESCH WHO IS A PRIVATE
CITIZEN BECAUSE SHE WANTS TO
KNOW WHY HE DIDN'T ACT ON
ANY OF THOSE 39 COMPLAINTS,
PEOPLE ARE NOT WILLING TO
MORTGAGE THEIR SELF-DEFENSE
RIGHTS TO THE GOVERNMENT AND
NOT A GOVERNMENT AS INEPT AS
ALL LEVELS WHETHER SCHOOL
DISTRICT, SHERIFF OR
FEDERAL.
ALL LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT
FAILED IN FLORIDA.
>> Tucker: THAT'S EXACTLY
RIGHT.
IF YOU ARE TELLING ME I
CAN'T DEFEND MYSELF AND YOU
ARE GOING TO PROTECT ME.